oh yes so Emma congratulations thank you
hiccups in from Germany
and I just wonder how will you celebrate
tonight and who that you could call to
us after the show my mom for sure and
I'm gonna go out with with a bunch of my
friends and dance and drink champagne
that's pretty much the only plan for
those two 20 and then back to 133 hi
Emma
hi hi congratulations thank you very
much even on different Comcast Xfinity
as what does it mean to you as one of
the ones who dreamed to have won this
award for playing this role that mimics
with so many people in this city go
through to get to the point of where
you're standing right now um well if I
guess surreal is probably the only way
to describe it it was I mean to play
this this woman I knew this I've lived
here for 13 years I moved when I was 15
to start auditioning and I knew what it
felt like to go on edition after
audition so I mean anything like this is
pretty inconceivable in a you know in a
realistic context so right now still
feels I had a really creepy little
moment backstage not to change the
subject but I just was like looking down
at it like it was my newborn child and I
think this is a statue of a naked man
very creepy sharing it so hopefully I'll
look at a newborn child differently but
I mean it's just yeah it's incredibly
surreal I don't have the benefit of
hindsight yet
that's a beautiful answer turned it into
a naked man story right at 1:30 stranded
down to 66 okay I'll give a scream on
how you doing how you doing you know
it's a dream you know to get an Oscar do
you ever dream like that I wanted a
dream when
announced you know as the best picture
golilong
Annie didn't win okay so yes of course
I'm an actor I've always dreamt of this
kind of thing but again not in a
realistic context and for that I [ __ ]
love moonlight God I love my life so
much I am so excited for moonlight and
of course you know it was an amazing
thing to hear lala land I think we all
would have loved to invest picture but
we are so excited for moonlight I think
it's one of the best films of all time
so I was pretty beside myself
I also was holding my Best Actress in a
leading role card that entire time so
whatever story I don't mean to start
stuff but whatever story that was I had
that card so I'm not sure what happened
did I really wanted to talk to you guys
first yeah
congratulations moonlight we're coming
to - Holly Aspen and temple we'll go
back to 74 I am a congratulations thank
you I'm fell calm could you just speak a
little bit to what the atmosphere was
like after that nothing does the
atmosphere in here is crazy
I think everyone's in a state of
confusion still excitement but confusion
so there's no real I I don't really have
a gauge of the atmosphere quite yet I
need to you know check in but I think I
think everyone is just so excited so
excited from in life it's just such an
incredible film sorry we're going to 74
and then 149 thank you congratulations
on the award a question from Bulgaria oh
how much does an Oscar cost in terms of
sacrifice and discipline oh my god is
that measurable I don't I don't know I
guess it depends on the Oscar for in in
my life I have been beyond lucky with
the people around me with the friends
and family that I have and the people
that have lifted me up throughout my
life so in terms of sacrifice
those people are all sitting back in a
room right now and I get to go celebrate
with them and it felt like the most
joyous thing so I mean being a creative
person does not feel like a like a
sacrifice to me it's the great joy of my
life and so I mean I don't know if
that's a you know good answer to that
question but I've been I've been very
lucky in terms of that we're going here
to 149 and then to 66 hi I'm Steve
Futterman from CBS News congratulations
on your award okay I'm just wondering as
a performer as someone who's been in
Hollywood you've experienced many things
before are you able to give us sort of a
word picture of what it was like I timed
it by the way 2 minutes and 30 seconds
la-la-land was best picture of the year
what was it like on stage when you first
bought you one you didn't win I know
you're taking a good stride in
everything again I don't know if this is
a measurable question is not the
craziest Oscar moment of all time cool
that we made history tonight craziest
moment and again I mean I don't I don't
even know what to say I think I was
still on such a buzzy train backstage
that I was you know on another planet
already so this is all just felt like
feather planet but again kind of looking
I'm like I'm so excited to do so it's
you know I think it's an incredible
outcome but very a very strange
happening for Oscar history thank you
we're going back to 66 and then we do
have to end with 277 over here hello my
name is Tammy on from Hong Kong
Apple Daily congratulations on your win
and my question is do you feel like
owing imma walk on a drink or dinner to
thank her for turning down the road oh
my god you know what she's doing great
she's the coolest she's Belle I mean I
think it's all right it's all good I
think she's amazing and we'll wrap it up
down front to your left
congratulations Emma Francisco Adela
finger I think other beads or sweat
dripping down my face look beautiful
amazing take a reservation
thank you being on the top of the world
right now what does it humble you um
well you know we have a nice little
jarring moment that's just you know it's
very it feels like real life but
everything kind of feels like real life
like this is an incredible incredible
honor and you know in many ways
game-changing for me personally but it's
also just still me and again back to the
people that I love with nothing changes
when I go home nothing's going to change
at all so I don't know that there's a
humbling moment it's just already like
feels ridiculous in the best way
thank you thank you so much and
congratulations thank you
[Applause]